Italy birth Ballet France helped codify
its terminology but it's Russia that
made this style of movement synonymous
with its identity if you look a lot of
the principal dancers a lot of the
dancers in the company they're either
head Russian teachers beta head Russian
training Russian has been on point when
it comes to fanciful footwork while in
the United States ballet is seen as
entertainment for the elites in Russia
it's mainstream culture during the Cold
War American use popular culture to
spread its views with things like movies
and television the Soviet Union
countered with high culture in the form
of music and ballet the role of ballet
in Russian culture has always been one
that's connected to the government
Valley it's not just something people do
or companies have done but rather that
this has become something that's seen as
deeply connected to political power hey
fam I'm a Mayan and this Sunday we're
starting to beat outside of our regular
studio and telling you how Russia
forever changed ballet
[Music]
why has ballet become synonymous with
Russia and Russians because we have the
great anton pankovitz knows ballet
because it's been his entire life
there's literally a book on him the
Russian born Stanford University
instructor has spent a lot of time on
his toes using releve Ron de Jong and
plie to have his body articulate what
words cannot in the neoclassical ballet
we tried to make of figures that not
necessarily human you can portray an
animal you can portray a tree can
portray many different things Peggy was
put on his first pair of ballet shoes at
age 10 and in doing so he stepped into
Russia's decades-long tradition of
ballet dominance they always put some
puss so much emphasis on culture culture
was extremely important to Russia coal
transport desert the one desert their
bread and butter and they always
succeeded in culture so many think of
ballet as a Russian art form but it was
actually the Italian to invented the
dance in the 15th century during the
Renaissance period ballet was how the
European royalty entertained itself says
dance historian lindara Pola they were
not public performances there were no
stages it wasn't public theater but
rather it was something that he could
clues to believe for the court the first
dancers didn't wear the tutus or the
pointe shoes we've come to associate
with the art today and the language
words like bar pirouette and porta bra
it comes from the French who adopted
ballet shortly after its creation ballet
didn't arrive to the United States until
the 1900s which is centuries after it
began its arrival coincided with a large
wave of Russians immigrating to the US
after the Russian Imperial government
was overthrown and years of civil war
followed Russia nearly abandoned ballet
following 1970s Bolshevik Revolution
that of people eventually birthed the
Soviet Union and a communist party that
would rule the nation for decades in
their votes aftermath the powers that be
tried to destroy what they saw as the
trappings of the era
prophecy revolution leader Lenin had
originally intended to close the
theaters but peasants and farmers kept
filling the audiences for the ballet
after the Revolution the number of
Russians from the ballet world of Moscow
and st. Petersburg but also many other
places increased enormously since the
Russian people wanted ballet and opera
the famous Bolshoi Theatre was saved as
the Russian Empire died and the Soviet
Union began more than two million people
fled the country and that number
includes more than 30,000 people who
came to the United States to escape
repression and the police state many of
those people were aristocrats and
professionals in fact the mariyinsky
theater in st. Petersburg lost a huge
number of people
after the Revolution and many of them
later turned up all around the world
from San Francisco with a huge valley
centered community in Paris New York
also had any number of people those
artists may have escaped Russia but they
didn't escape her very watchful eye you
have to realize this was during the
height of the Cold War the US and the
Soviet Union were two world powers with
drastically differing ideologies and the
close watch the Soviets kept on their
dances is just one example of their
contrasts you were being constantly
watched then you had to worry about what
happened afterwards and the parents the
colleagues the fellow dancers family all
of these would be subjected to
surveillance and threats by the secret
police and by the political authority of
sometimes years before a dancer would be
able to talk to his or her mother for
instance or it's someone close but even
when you did you knew that someone was
listening to the phone conversation
coming to America wasn't easy for Soviet
ballet dancers but the outcome of all of
Russia's unrest did forever change the
art in the United States it's Russian
choreographer George Balanchine who
became the father of the American Ballet
when he co-founded the School of
American Ballet in 1934 Russia's Ballet
Russe War had sparked an American
interest in the dance and Russian
defectors began to share their training
today you can enroll in ballet class
just about anywhere in the US if it
wasn't for Balanchine
I don't
thing Valley would have been as popular
in America a Russian ballet has
influenced pretty much I believe all of
American dancin the Soviet connection is
clear it's in the execution where
pankovitz says you'll see the difference
he compared the two styles to a car race
it's like watching Indy 500 versus
Formula One which one's Indian which
one's Formula one D is American Indy 500
Formula One is a European so formula
once you have the fastest technology in
the world and you have the most amazing
races what they haven't any indeed they
just go in a circle look at the
difference in the speed of the footwork
on the left is the Russian way and on
the right is the American Way
carefully says the Soviet Union is also
the reason ballet saw an increase in the
quality of male dancers the Soviet early
on had decided had put a premium on the
quality of male dancing and so many of
the roles were increased augmented new
variations new solos would be added and
it was this tradition of male dancing
that the Soviets brought to the west and
electrified people Mikhail Baryshnikov
is one of the Soviets most famous male
dancers he's considered one of the
greatest ballet dancers in history and
he's actually the pre-eminent male
dancer of the 1970s and the 1980s at a
time when one of the only ways Soviets
could see the world was through touring
with the Arts
Baryshnikov wild international audiences
with his ability and in June 1974 he
wowed them with his affection from the
Soviet Union it was a big deal yes
ballet is about strength and beauty but
for the Soviets it was also about power
their art was a way to try and persuade
people to the Soviet worldview without
force or coercion in this way Soviet
dancers introducing their style to a
global audience was a sort of propaganda
in the same way the West also used soft
power like having the CIA back abstract
expressionist painters like Jackson
Pollock or producing movies like James
Bond which cast the Soviets has the bad
guy his murder of Tom I did the Iron
Curtain
I believe the Soviets felt that this was
one way of encountering what was the
vast American influence abroad and what
essentially America exported although
certainly didn't do so consciously and
this led of course to a wonderful period
of touring by Soviet companies so this
couldn't have happened in the US without
the Soviets because they essentially
created the American version of ballet
pankovitz valise Russia will continue to
dominate ballet because of the amount of
monetary resources the government
contributes to sustain the arc and for
him the most difficult part of ballet is
it securing the funding I would say the
most difficult thing about ballet is
letting go you have a certain memories
that you remember how you look it's hard
to let it go because you have a certain
memory and just don't dwell on the past
and trying to share your memory with the
dancers hey guys thanks so much for
watching don't forget to Like share and
subscribe we spent the last several
weeks covering all kinds of communities
Cambodians Russian West Indians tell us
what you want us to cover in the
comments and we'll see you next Sunday